is hans neiman who defeated mission
depot with the black pieces
hans welcome to the studio tell us a
little bit about your tournament so far
topsy-turvy you started off with a very
exciting game against ray robson you
were winning then you were losing then
it ended up in a draw then you won a
game then you lost the game and now you
finally won with the black pieces tell
us a little bit about your tournament
and how you assess it
i think it's a pretty bad event
from a
result perspective but um i think that
the results have not been reflective of
of my play i think in as you mentioned
and a few specific critical moments
things sort of
didn't go my way
like in this robson game
um you know i um in time pressure missed
a win and a few other games some results
have flipped
so i think i've actually been playing
very well i'm very happy with my play
i'm just not that happy with how i've
managed my nerves in the critical
moments but i think in general i've
shown
pretty good chess especially today and
against my winning winning slenderman as
well absolutely today was a very
clinical performance especially in the
endgame let's take a look at that game
when did you feel like your opponent is
starting to er
um that's a very fancy vocabulary word
christian i think it's i'm glad that
you've been studying
um i almost couldn't understand that one
um utd education right there thank you
yeah well it's but you know where you
can get a better education than utd at
museums
however if you are ambitious about your
chess stay away from college i'll i'll
put that last thing in anyways um yeah
so i had this you know you see they got
this d5 idea this was a nice little
opening tidbit but uh you know when i
had like 50 minutes against
uh 30 seconds in a much better position
i started to feel that he went wrong but
um yeah i think this opening idea was
actually played
um
it was actually for the first time or
in the second time actually
um it was in a classical game was played
um rob's dragoon against robson
and he won that game to show this idea
but this is like a so i prepared for
this game
i assume that he was sort of aware of it
because of you know following the other
games but he didn't really react
properly here
and um
in relation to the other game i'm going
to nerd out here you know some people
might just
think i'm think i'm not uh
might i get this but in this position
you know with the bishop on b5 and the
rook and i phase transposing to the game
so here you know uh this is sort of you
know we were debating after the game
where there's an improvement
but having the working i thought it was
an improvement especially after after he
took and played 93 which is not really
the most precise so if the bishop takes
bishop takes uh there's the same
position in the robson game but the rook
was an f8 the bishop wasn't b5 so from a
logical perspective
one concluded the rook on the 8th is
good like
i guess he disagreed but uh i thought
that this is just a fine improvement so
this was certainly winning the opening
battle and then i think i just
it was a clinical positional game after
that yeah you can go through it but yeah
so here yeah so this is queen d5 uh 97
this is i saw this move and i was like
did i blunder
and then i realized you know queen b3
ab3 and there's qb3 i have king f7
so this position king f7 takes king f6
was just really interesting because uh
he you know it looks like white could be
better because this there's some weird
tension and some concrete issues with
the weak c7 pawn and also there's to
defend this pawn there's also the f3
break and then if you defend rookie
seven like i put in the game this is b4
break there's a lot of you know nuances
and
weird ideas here
but i think the most important thing you
didn't really understand is that if i
play the move g5 he's just never going
to be better
and
after rookie 7
b4 g5 bishop d2 rookie 8 i've sort of
gotten rid of these concrete issues and
now i'm ready to just uh play on the
king side and think like you know okay
from all
general perspectives like my king is is
very good his king is bad
um my position can improve much more
than
in his scan with just extending on the
king side so it's not really clear he's
just a bit a bit too weak um
so
yeah this is where things i started to
feel optimistic
so okay b5 knight e7 c4
um
f4
well i didn't play four i can't even
remember
b6 yes i saw you play that f4 thank you
thank you yes now okay yeah so so before
this is another so here if you go back
like before f3 um this is where you know
okay so i if i remember he had like 15
minutes through 53 he has six
and um
if he doesn't play f3 he can sort of
wait
and he's probably not like lost but he's
just going to get slowly you know
squeezed
um as i see carl says you know like
squeezing some orange juice you know
and uh pineapple juice
pineapple juice you know and and just
you know you guys are shipping on twitch
i gotta like get some clips for you so
you guys can boost your viewership and
get the car watching the stream like i'm
doing you guys a favor right here you
know just even mentioning kikara will
get you
you know a lot more viewers i know you
guys have been waiting for me just to
come on and do this interview because
you just needed some content you know so
i will give you your value there we go
um
so
you know he could have just so here's
this is a thing because he gets low on
time and he's like okay i got we got to
go we got to go he just starts blitzing
and and going for really risky stuff and
everything just collapsed um so i can if
there's a critical moment i will stop
yeah so c5 knight d4
okay yeah so if
am i lost here's the question
because so here i made a little bit of a
calculated risk i was like this guy's
got two minutes
i see what he should do i just don't
think he's going to do it with with uh
that much of the clock so after rookie
ate ricky hit
he's supposed to take on b6 or what yeah
takes on b6
knight f3 knight f3 and i was like if if
he plays this with two minutes on the
clock h1 maybe
i would i just i just i i submitted 20
years king h1 ricky's two rookie two or
three two so king f2 i calculated king
f2
i king of two as well and i was like
okay takes on b6 let's see seven i guess
and then
i was like okay knight c4
and rick c8 see one rook c1 rook c1
knight d6
and apparently
after b6 i just
maybe i'm just
get a calculation
so i was like i saw this but i was like
nah he's not going to play like and i
saw this in maybe like 15 seconds but i
was like just no she's not going to play
so i was like
i think i was lost yeah no but rook c
rook c8
i don't really know why you're lost but
i'm going to pretend like this brick
stage rookie one for q1
you know what
knight b7 knight p7 yeah
and then
it does look a bit dangerous okay maybe
i'm not lost
maybe i'm not lost you know my
calculation wasn't really in the best my
conclusion was there's no way and if i
lose this i lose this but if i don't go
for this i'm not gonna win the game you
know so we you gotta risk it for the
biscuit you know have you learned that
phrase christian i know that i know that
one yeah you have okay
okay
uh so
you know he didn't go for this
yeah i'm cheating a little bit but it is
precisely because he has to go to either
f2 or g2 and g2 slightly worse because
it gets it allows rookie two later
is that you actually have this check uh
on on e4 instead of going through c4
and uh this is apparently an important
tempo because well the p6 doesn't come
with a threat
uh so you could you you after b6 what do
i play
uh b6 it's it's not it says point eight
after route uh rookie three rookie three
ah rookie three right right b3 okay get
behind the pawns so you know my instinct
was you know just full cent you know if
you're a fan of enough boys um
which i don't think any of you guys so
much culture
you know i just think you should just
full send it for the boys yeah we'll
send it for the boys yeah my god i have
never felt so old like i feel right now
i am just trying to help you guys get
more viewers you know i'm a nice guy
you've never had a happy dad
oh the happy dance you know if i was old
enough i'd be drinking happy dads
all right hunger is completely lost
we made it to day seven without going
crazy but this is the end guys we are
finito we are done
all right hans good job good win uh
good stuff thank you also please look at
the logos yeah there we go if i'm
farming content yeah shout out to my
sponsors trustable 24.
excellent chess 24 great company and are
you going to be working for them anytime
soon
yeah um i'm a brand ambassador you know
i am doing some streaming for them i'll
be playing in the next tour event i
believe so doing some streaming
promotional stuff
growing the beautiful game of chess and
you know in a cool stylish way with
weird shirts and buzz cuts
for the boys for the boys lebron was
doing that before all right
thank you hans for joining us always an
entertaining character certainly with an
autopsy turvy tournament and let's try
to finish up on what's going on with
today's round